Steph Curry is fixing a problem with his
shoe brand pointed out by a
nine-year-old girl
Riley Morrison wrote him a letter asking
why his Curry five sneakers were being
marketed to boys and were not available
in girls sizes in her words girls want a
rock the shoes - Riley was amazed when
curry wrote back in a CBS this morning
Saturday co-host Michelle Miller reports
she couldn't be happier about it girls
play basketball - and it's it's not any
more important for boys than girls
Riley Morrison got an unexpected reply
Thursday morning to a letter she wrote I
was really surprised and excited Riley
who was starting a new basketball season
had asked her dad to buy her Steph
Curry's curry five basketball shoes but
when he went to the website Chris
Morrison was surprised to see they were
only available under the boys section I
was thinking like this isn't fair Riley
took action writing to curry I know you
support girl athletes because you have
two daughters and you hosted all girls
basketball camp I hope you can work with
Under Armour to change this because
girls want to rock the curry fives -
after Riley's dad posted the letter on
Instagram curry did just that tweeting
appreciate you helping us get better
Riley we got you along with a
handwritten response unfortunately we
have labeled smaller sizes as boys on
the website we are correcting this now I
want to make sure you can wear my kicks
proudly the fact that he took the time
out of his day to rights and my daughter
means a lot to me not only was the
change made on the underarmor website
but curry said he would send Riley a
pair of the shoes and she would be one
of the first kids to get the curry sixes
I'm just super happy that they've made
the change and now it's on there and I'm
really proud of her for making a
difference Riley is satisfied that all
girls can now find the shoes in their
section
boys aren't the only ones that want them
everybody wants them ain't that the
truth well curry also invited Riley to
come to Oakland for a special event
that's in the works for International
Women's Day on March the 8th and Riley
says of course she can't wait so
hopefully he'll get to meet his daughter
she'll get to meet his daughter Riley -
I have a Riley who's 10 she's also the
only girl on the boys basketball go food
run a world that's Riley I'm proud of
Under Armour I'm proud of Steph Curry
and let me just note too though this
extends beyond baseball so I hope other
sports companies take notice
fascinating rather thank you thank you